there were a bunch of Epic fights in the
New Black Clover movie but the one that
takes the cake is definitely the fight
between Asta and Conrad letto because
who doesn't want to see our protagonist
fight a wizard King Benton destroying
the entire nation no God the fight has
high stakes and a clash of ideals takes
place backed up with stunning animation
from Studio Piero which is heavenly
compared to the series everything from
Conrad's attacks to asta's demon form
was eye candy to any anime fan with the
country on the line Asta uses the
Imperial sword along with his demon form
and clashes with Conrad's spell leading
to one of the most stunning sequences in
the entire fight it's not just the
animation even the soundtrack was
magical all we can say is the Wake was
definitely worth it
I gotta tell you it was perfect
perfect